The Christmas Truce of WWI
On the whole, people don’t generally like
to kill one another.
Most wars throughout history are often more
about the agendas of the state’s leaders
than the soldiers on the field actually inherently
feeling any real malice towards those they
are asked to try to kill or otherwise defeat.
Few events in history illustrate this as well
as a remarkable episode that took place during
WWI when, despite the orders of their commanding
officers and leaders, the soldiers threw aside
their weapons, got out of the trenches and
had a make-shift Christmas party with those
that just hours before they’d been trying
to kill.
This momentous event has become known as The
Christmas Truce.
Leading up to this impromptu truce in 1914,
Pope Benedict XV had asked that the various
governments participating in the war would
negotiate a truce for one day, so that “the
guns may fall silent at least upon the night
the angels sang.”
There was also an “Open Christmas Letter”
sent out by British women’s suffragists
to the women of Germany and Austria, asking
for peace.
(The German women’s suffragists responded
in kind and an exchange of letters ensued
where they discussed peace and the horror
of “modern” war.)
In the United States, a resolution was submitted
in the Senate attempting to get the warring
countries to stop fighting for 20 days leading
up to and including Christmas “with the
hope that the cessation of hostilities at
the said time may stimulate reflection upon
the part of the nations at war as to the meaning
and spirit of Christmas time.”
The leaders of the warring nations paid little
attentions to these attempts at peace.
The American weekly, The New Republic, noted
just before Christmas of 1914,
“If men must hate, it is perhaps just as
well that they make no Christmas truce…
The stench of the battle should rise above
the churches where they preach good-will to
men.
A few carols, a little incense and some tinsel
will heal no wounds…
[A truce would be] so empty that it jeers
at us.”
But a somewhat alarming (to the commanding
officers and leaders of the nations) trend
had already started occurring amongst the
troops on both sides leading up to the truce.
Stuck knee deep in their muddy trenches along
lines so close together, the soldiers on both
sides, who’d commonly thrown insults back
and forth, started adopting a slightly more
apathetic view of the war, more of a “live
and let live” policy.
In some cases, they even started tossing newspapers
and other things back and forth, bartering
for supplies like cigarettes, rations and
the like, and holding conversations across
the trenches.
As one Royal Engineer, Andrew Todd said,
“Perhaps it will surprise you to learn that
the soldiers in both lines of trenches have
become very ‘pally’ with each other.
The trenches are only 60 yards apart at one
place, and every morning about breakfast time
one of the soldiers sticks a board in the
air.
As soon as this board goes up all firing ceases,
and men from either side draw their water
and rations.
All through the breakfast hour, and so long
as this board is up, silence reigns supreme,
but whenever the board comes down, the first
unlucky devil who shows even so much as a
hand gets a bullet through it.”
Another such temporary truce instance occurred
on December 19, (recounted by Lieutenant Geoffrey
Heinekey):
“…a most extraordinary thing happened…
Some Germans came out and held up their hands
and began to take in some of their wounded
and so we ourselves immediately got out of
our trenches and began bringing in our wounded
also.
The Germans then beckoned to us and a lot
of us went over and talked to them and they
helped us to bury our dead.
This lasted the whole morning and I talked
to several of them and I must say they seemed
extraordinarily fine men…
It seems too ironical for words.
There, the night before we had been having
a terrific battle and the morning after, there
we were smoking their cigarettes and they
smoking ours.”
This type of behavior, perhaps inherent in
any war where the two sides have to live and
fight in such close proprieties and for such
a long duration, began popping up more and
more in sections of the line, prompting the
army leaders to issue strict orders forbidding
any fraternization with the “enemy”.
These incidents of temporary peace along the
line typically didn’t last very long and
were never wide spread, happening in very
small pockets.
This changed on Christmas Eve of 1914 beginning
along the trenches near Ypres, Belgium.
It is reported that it started with the Germans
setting up Christmas trees, singing carols,
and lighting candles.
The British and French then responded in kind,
singing along, and soon the two sides in various
places along the line were wishing each other
happy holidays.
Even more surprising between these two groups
that were previously exchanging shots and
explosives was that they now began exchanging
Christmas gifts, handshakes, hugs, playing
games, drinking, and generally having a good
time with one another.
There are even reports of prayer circles formed
with members of both sides taking part.
In a letter home, one British soldier wrote,
“Just you think, that while you were eating
your turkey…, I was out talking and shaking
hands with the very men I had been trying
to kill a few hours before!
It was astounding!”
Another soldier, Bruce Barinsfather noted,
“I wouldn’t have missed that unique and
weird Christmas Day for anything.
… I spotted a German officer, some sort
of lieutenant I should think, and being a
bit of a collector, I intimated to him that
I had taken a fancy to some of his buttons.
… I brought out my wire clippers and, with
a few deft snips, removed a couple of his
buttons and put them in my pocket.
I then gave him two of mine in exchange.
… The last I saw was one of my machine gunners,
who was a bit of an amateur hairdresser in
civil life, cutting the unnaturally long hair
of a docile Boche (German), who was patiently
kneeling on the ground whilst the automatic
clippers crept up the back of his neck.”
Those who were less enthusiastic about being
friendly with their enemy also took advantage
of this time, burying the dead and fortifying
their trenches without fear of being shot.
However, even then the spirit of friendliness
seemed to be prevalent.
As one solder noted in a letter home, “I
honestly believe, that if I called on the
Saxons for fatigue parties to help with our
barbed wire, they would have come over and
done so.”
Many soldiers wrote similar accounts in letters
sent back home about the truce, but as this
sort of behavior went against the massive
propaganda campaigns going on at home, trying
to stir the general populace up against the
“enemy”, the governments on both sides
suppressed these letters and kept them out
of the media for a short time.
This ended when the New York Times published
a story on the event on December 31st.
On January 1, 1915, The South Wales Echo also
published an account of the event, stating
“When the history of the war is written,
one of the episodes which chroniclers will
seize upon as one of its most surprising features
will undoubtedly be the manner in which the
foes celebrated Christmas.
How they fraternized in each other’s trenches,
played football, rode races, held sing-songs,
and scrupulously adhered to their unofficial
truce will certainly go down as one of the
greatest surprises of a surprising war.”
The next day the Daily Mirror even went so
far as to say that the only real wartime hostilities
that didn’t need to be forced were those
going on at home thanks to a “gospel of
hate” spread by the nation’s leaders (who
incidentally, once the cat was out of the
bag, tried extremely hard to downplay the
extent of the Christmas truce, in direct contradiction
to many of the soldier’s letters).
An excerpt from The Daily Mirror‘s article:
“The soldier’s heart rarely has any hatred
in it.
He goes out to fight because that is his job.
What came before- the causes of the war and
the why and wherefore- bother him little.
He fights for his country and against his
country’s enemies.
Collectively, they are to be condemned and
blown to pieces.
Individually, he knows they’re not bad sorts…
The soldier has other things to think about…
Consequently, he has not time for rage, and
blind furies only overwhelm him when the blood
is up over fierce tussles in the heat of the
thing.
At other times, the childishness is apparent
to him…
But now an end to the truce.
The news, bad and good, begins again.
1915 darkens over.
Again we who watch have to mourn many of our
finest men.
The lull is finished.
The absurdity and the tragedy renew themselves.”
Bonus Fact:
• About 17 million people were killed and
another 20 million were injured as a result
of WWI.